E aí
e em 2011 eu estava no palco do programa
da Eliana para poder cantar uma música
em rede nacional Sim eu já cantei na
televisão eu estava lá junto com algumas
amigas para poder cantar uma música que
a gente fez um trabalho de escola uma
paródia de Telephone da Lady Gaga e
Beyoncé só que ensinando Fórmula de
geometria a música original que era top
kohlenstoff Collins a don't talk Anymore
alemã here my heart on the dance floor
virou área do Cone área do Cone eu vou
ensinar para você vai ao quadrado +
Pierre g na época essa música viralizou
na internet bombou no YouTube eu fui
parar na Globo no SBT e na Record E aí
ver e até Outdoor e assim foi a primeira
web Hit hoje eu spartakus Santiago sou
youtuber trabalho com isso já acumula
mais de 80 milhões de views na internet
mas tudo começou ali graças ao que eu
aprendi com
E aí
e naquela época eu era só um garoto
jovem negro gay de Itabuna no interior
da Bahia que nem tem direito quem era
e eu era muito inseguro Na época eu já
gostava de Lady Gaga de Beyoncé de
várias divas pop mas eu tinha muita
vergonha disso porque todo mundo me
dizia que era coisa de e que eu
não podia gostar
e eu lembro que no intervalo eu ficava
lá tentando aprender a coreografia de
cereais E aí os garotos me zoando
ridicularizando Eu lembro por exemplo
que teve um dia que eu aprendi a
progressiva completa The Love Game da
Lady Gaga que é dificílima gravei um
vídeo coloquei no meu canal do YouTube e
eu cheguei no colégio achando que eu
tava arrasando e as meninas vieram me
falar que aquilo era ridículo que aquilo
era uma vergonha que eu devia pagar
Oi e eu apaguei porque assim eu não
tinha muitos amigos eu era Solitário eu
era o único da sala que nunca tinha
beijado na boca
Oi e eu tava cansado disso sabe
o tanto que teve uma hora que eu falei
chega eu falei assim cara eu não quero
mais ser rejeitado não quero mais ser
excluído eu quero ser feliz eu mereço
ser feliz e sim para ser feliz eu tenho
que ser macho então você macho e eu
peguei os meus CDs de diva pop daí para
minha prima parei de ouvir essas músicas
parei de andar com meus amigos que
também eram Finados mudei as minhas
roupas e comecei a tentar ser amigo dos
garotos que me zoavam que fazer um
bullying comigo para ver se eu se eu
virava um deles sabe para ver se eu
conseguia enfim ficar um cara seguro
feliz e tal
Oi foi péssimo
o tipo durante um ano eu acordava todo
dia quem tava ser o que eu não era e foi
horrível eu acabei até virando amigos de
alguns deles mas isso não mudou quem era
eu continuava achando que eu tinha tido
um problema em ter nascido desse jeito
e até que Lady Gaga lançou uma música em
2011 chamada Born This Way que dizia in
the Religion of the insecure You must Be
Myself respect my Youth ou seja na
religião da insegurança eu devo ser eu
mesmo respeitar Minha Juventude e aí ela
me ensinou a primeira lição
O que autenticidade é uma forma de amor
próprio
o que eu ser eu mesmo era algo muito
mais eficiente para poder conseguir ser
seguro do que menu lá para agradar os
outros porque isso era respeitar minha
identidade isso é a respeitar Minha
Juventude meu tempo aqui na terra e isso
é a partir daí que eu parei de tentar
ser o que não era e eu comecei a mostrar
esse meu lado que é mesmo na
escola e os a Lady Gaga como inspiração
para os trabalhos e foi aí que eu
brilhei foi que eu bombei foi que eu fui
parar no YouTube na televisão e foi aí
que elas duas começaram a mudar minha
vida
e eu inclusive por causa disso desistir
de fazer direito quero um curso para
fazer só para agradar minha família e
que eu já tinha sido aprovado para poder
fazer publicidade uma profissão que
expor a minha criatividade
Oi e aí eu me mudei para o Sudeste para
o Rio de Janeiro para Niterói para poder
fazer publicidade e sendo publicitário
eu entendi a Lady Gaga mais ainda porque
eu entendi que é possível você vender
qualquer produto com embalagem certo ela
já falou sobre críticas a indústria da
fama disfarçadas de músicas românticas
no seu álbum the Fame Monster ela já
falou de militância LGBT em Born This
Way sobre discussões e saúde mental em
cromática ela para mim sempre foi uma
intelectual disfarçada de compositora
uma Rebelde disfarçada de diva pop uma
Gaga disfarçada de leite
e em Judas ela fala em demos biblical
sense I am Beyond repentance hooker
prostitutes witches Your Mind and count
rows and I speak in Future tense Ou seja
no sentido mais bíblico eu estou além do
arrependimento sua prostituta da fama
que vomita a sua mente mas no sentido
cultural eu só estou falando no tempo
futuro me ensinando que é possível você
popularizar ideias através de uma
linguagem de massa que por mais que
achassem que ela tava se prostituindo
pela forma para chamar atenção ela na
verdade estava produzindo que as pessoas
queriam consumir como forma de poder
embalar e amplificar um discurso que
buscava transformar a cultura e
sociedade
e usando essa fórmula eu consegui fazer
com que mais de meio milhão de pessoas
há quase uma década atrás aprendessem
fórmulas de geometria disfarçada de
música pop e hoje no meu canal e
continua fazendo a mesma coisa eu falo
sobre questões sociais sobre racismo
sobre LGBT fobia mas tudo isso
disfarçado de análise de clipe de álbuns
de singles tudo isso disfarçado de
entretenimento porque quando eu falo o
que eu realmente quero falar as pessoas
acham que é chato que é vitimismo enfim
só que ela é gata também me ensinou que
você ter coragem para ser diferente faz
você se destacar mas nem sempre de uma
forma positiva
é a mesma coragem para ser bizarra que
fez ela ficar famosa e tem muitos fãs e
fazer muito sucesso no início da
carreira com o Tempo começou a fazer ela
ser vista como alguém desesperada por
atenção alguém que só queria causar
alguém que foi taxada como fracassada no
álbum Artpop
e ela me mostrou que é preciso negociar
constantemente o com diferente você pode
ser porque se você for diferente demais
você é punido e eu digo para vocês como
negro e gay eu sei exatamente o que é
ser punido por ser diferente
é tanto é que depois de ser Gaga demais
no algumas pop ser bizarra demais ela
precisou lançar um álbum de jazz um
álbum de country e ganhar um oscar para
poder recuperar o status de laser é
importante luzon ela fala igualzinho
Love e o Perfect ilusion ou seja não era
amor era uma perfeita ilusão e mostrando
que é uma ilusão achar que se destacar
significa apenas ser amado
e eu por exemplo no início do meu canal
eu me posicionava muito contra as coisas
que me incomodavam
e eu fazia várias denúncias de casos de
racismo eu ia lá e fazer vídeos contra
políticos LGBT fóbicos para que eles não
fossem eleitos e por mais que eu me
destacasse por isso eu também paguei um
preço eu virei alvo de fake News eu
passei por um linchamento
e eu enfim desenvolver sintomas de
ansiedade e depressão
Ah e quem me ensinou a entender como
lidar com isso foi a Beyoncé
É porque ela sempre me mostrou que é
preciso dançar conforme a música para só
depois você me dava que é preciso jogar
o jogo para só depois você mudar suas
regras
e ela durante muito tempo canto Halo e
Single Ladies para só depois canta
formation
e ela precisou durante uma boa parte da
sua carreira ser uma naughty Girl uma
mulher negra sensual que as pessoas
querem consumir para só depois ela ir lá
no intervalo do super bom e homenagear
os panteras negras protestando contra a
brutalidade policial
bom então para mim era um exemplo do que
pessoas negras passam ao buscar adentrar
espaços de poder espaços em branco
tecidos se você é uma voz Negra Que se
posiciona demais você é punido a Nina
Simone por exemplo é um dos maiores
exemplos disso que foi boicotada Carrera
toda porque se posicionava demais
não é preciso ser muito estratégico para
você conseguir falar o que você pensa e
não ser visto como agressivo como hiit
mista é preciso ser paciente é preciso
ser didático para você ser ouvido porque
senão você é punido senão você é
penalizado as maiores referências de
militância que nós temos Martin Luther
King Malcom ex Mariele foram todos
assassinados então é preciso ser muito
estratégico para você conseguir falar o
que você pensa esse funcionar e
sobreviver no sistema racista
e outra coisa que haviam se me ensina é
que se você é negra você tem que
trabalhar o dobro para você conseguir
que você quer
o information ela fala aí Dream work
hard Ground you I onete Ou seja eu sonho
eu trabalho duro e o ralo até consegui
porque nessa falsa meritocracia que a
gente está inserido se você é negra você
tem que trabalhar duro tem que trabalhar
muito para poder compensar o racismo que
te inferioriza e a biomm se faz isso ela
trabalha muito ela ensaia muito e chegar
lá entrega performances incríveis e
alguns visuais com qualidade técnica com
sei lá profundidade política e mesmo
assim ela não é valorizada como artistas
brancos que não se só só uma metade ela
foi lá no costela e fez aquela
performance Econômica surreal parecendo
quase um ciborgue E aí mesmo assim ela
foi derrotado em premiações por Branco
Santana Karaokê
é só que mesmo assim ela continua ela
foca nas suas vitórias e não nas suas
derrotas Porque como ela fala em Freedom
a o Keep Running cause we don't Kid
yourself eu vou continuar correndo e
seguir em frente porque um Vencedor não
desiste de si mesmo e mais do que isso
como ela fala em aulas rir a dia sua
André entrou Era Games maior de uma Bros
somante o rappi nesse make This world a
little better just cuz I love you eu só
quero que as pessoas saibam que eu dei
tudo de mim que eu fiz o meu melhor que
eu trouxe a felicidade para alguém que
eu fiz esse mundo um pouco melhor porque
eu estava aqui
o ensinando que sucesso de verdade não é
reconhecimento
o sucesso de verdade é você impactar
positivamente a vida dos outros
e isso é o que as duas me ensinaram que
mais importante do que você usar sua voz
para entreter para falar algo
superficial algo shellow é você tem uma
mensagem é você buscar criar um legado
e a gaga mais do que me fazer dançar ela
me ajudou até orgulho de ser gay
e a biomm se mais do que me fazer cantar
me ajudou tem orgulho de ser negro e as
duas me mostraram que quando eu parava
de esconder que não era eu que gostava
porque as pessoas vão julgar porque a
diva pop porque ai é coisa de é
colorido An Era quando eu finalmente
parava de reprimir a mim mesmo minha
criatividade flui a e o brilhava
e elas me ensinaram que o que nos faz
diferente na verdade nosso diferencial
que o que me fazia ser rejeitado na
verdade podia ser a fonte do meu Sucesso
era só usar isso com o motor criativo
elas me ensinaram mais do que tudo que
eu ter nascido desse jeito negro e gay
não era um problema e sim uma
oportunidade de transformar Limões em
limonada Muito obrigado
E aí
[Aplausos]